[Musique]
il fait chaud
bonjour on se retrouve aujourd'hui pour
une vidéo portrait format assez rare sur
place et sauvage pour le souligner d'une
personnalité qui a marqué
l'anthropologie du xxème siècle n'a
regard est vide
cet épisode est aussi le dernier de la
saison passée sauvage devient
tachycardie sauvages n'ent écoutez je
n'ai pas prévu de publier cet été pour
la simple et bonne raison que je pense
qu'on a tous envie de faire autre chose
cet été que de regarder des vidéos
youtube surtout après l'année qu'on
vient de passer
donc on se retrouve en septembre petite
parenthèse j'ai un code promo à vous
proposer un code pour mot pour nantes
vpn vous utiliser ce code la passe et
sauvage et vous avez droit à 70 % de
réduction sur les abonnements mensuels
c'est un code affilié c'est dire que je
touche une commission pour chaque
abonnement souscrit
voilà toutes les infos sont dans la
barre dédiée sous la vidéo on enchaîne
et si vous ne savez pas ce qu'est un vpn
regarder n'importe quelle vidéo de
youtube heures en 2020 ils le font tous
bien mieux que moi
[Musique]
anthropologue américaine margaret mid
réalise de longs séjours d'études en
océanie entre 1920 et 1940
elle y développe une pensée originale
analysant notamment l'adolescence et le
genre ces sujets d'étude tout comme ses
divorces à répétition ou encore ses
prises de position sur la bisexualité
choque l'amérique puritaine de
l'entre-deux-guerres aventurière
intrépide devenue icône féministe
pionnière des études de genre ayant subi
une avalanche de critiques
on revient dans cette vidéo sur la vie
et l'oeuvre de marguerite mid
[Musique]
né à philadelphie en 1901 d'un père
professeur d'économie à l'université et
d'une mère diplômée de sociologie mid et
familiariser dès l'enfance avec les
sciences sociales
elle rentre à l'université de columbia à
20 ans en 1921 pour étudier la
psychologie et l'anthropologie
là bas elle est formée par franz boas et
son assistante luz bénédicte russe
bénédicte russe
ruth route rugby obsédé par l'idée
d'être utile et de sauvegarder des
cultures exotiques en train de
disparaître
elle entre en anthropologie comme on
entre en religion prêt à se rendre à
l'autre bout du monde pour accomplir sa
mission
à peine mariée avec luther kressmann un
pasteur protestant qui étudie la
sociologie elle par salou sannois en
1925 elle s'installe au dispensaire de
l'île de thau à l'est de l'archipel et
devient rapidement le centre d'attention
des jeunes filles de l'île qui passent
toute leur journée avec elle
en neuf mois mid récolte ainsi les plus
infimes et intimes détails de la vie de
ces adolescentes
c'est à partir de leurs témoignages
qu'elle construit son étude est publiée
à son retour adolescence à samoa en 1927
l'objectif de son livre et de comparer
l'adolescence aux samoa et aux états
unis
finalement elle conclut que l'adolescent
sosa noir n'est donc en aucune façon une
période de crise et de tensions mais
bien au contraire une évolution de calme
la maturité cette position vient
fortement nuancer les croyances de
l'époque sur l'adolescence comme un
moment de crise obligatoires ce premier
livre incertaine écho aux états unis et
midi est encouragé à poursuivre ses
recherches sur le bateau du retour des
samoa mid rencontre un jeune psychologue
néo zélandais ray ou fortune cherchez
pas il n'y a pas plus classe comme non
non mais j'ai cherché un mic john jerome
ça fait pas pareil
ils se rendent tous les deux en europe
et passe la traversée a parlé avec
passion d'anthropologie de psychologie
ils finissent par débarquer à marseille
six semaines plus tard amoureux elle
rentre aux états unis en 1926 et
s'attelle à la rédaction de son livre
son terrain l'a toutefois profondément
changé avec son mari pasteur protestant
et sociologue mid avait imaginé vivre
dans un presbytère avoir au moins six
enfants est consacré sa vie à aider les
nécessiteux au retour des samoa ce
projet semble définitivement oubliée
d'autant que mid apprend à l'automne
1926 qu'elle a une malformation l'utérus
qui rend pratiquement impossible d'avoir
des enfants
elle choisit donc de se séparer de son
mari au printemps 27 et embarque pour la
nouvelle-zélande
retrouvez réaux fortune elle choisit
volontairement quelqu'un qui elle le
sait ne ferait pas un père idéal mais
avec qui elle pourra se consacrer à
l'ethnographie terrain
[Musique]
dès qu'il se retrouve réaux et margaret
se marient et embarque pour les îles de
l'amirauté au nord de la nouvelle guinée
là bas elle s'intéresse aux mêmes
questions qu'à sa mort est publié en
1930 une éducation en nouvelle guinée
qui enrichit sa théorie très marquée par
une approche psychologique mid établi en
fait un lien entre les dispositions
psychique des individus et les cultures
qu'elle observe sur le terrain elle
décrit en quelque sorte le tempérament
la personnalité des cultures qu'elle
entreprend de classer selon quatre types
principaux elle utilise pour cela les
points cardinaux
c'est sur son terrain suivant réaliser
toujours en nouvelle guinée
mais sur la grande île cette fois ci
entre fin 31 et début 33 qu'elle peut
déployer toute sa théorie en descendant
le fleuve ses piques
elle s'emploie à comparer trois sociétés
des arts à pêche et moun do more et
l'etg embolie son travail est publié
sous le titre
trois sociétés primitives de nouvelle
guinée mais peut-être que vous
connaissez plus tôt cette édition 2009
135 chez plon north et sexualité en
océanie qui en fait regroupent et trois
textes dont je viens de vous parler ce
genre trucs qui traînent dans les
bibliothèques des années 70 chez les
grands parents peut-être vos parents
voilà les chiffres les chiffres est
passé sauvage ils datent pas du tout 35
ce livre hilda 2,63
je revérifie oui 63 il ne regroupe pas
trois textes mais deux donc trois
sociétés primitives de nouvelle guinée
et adolescence asamoah voilà c'est tout
on y retourne dans cet ouvrage elle se
concentre sur la question des genres et
de la construction des identités en
mettant en évidence de profondes
différences dans la façon de concevoir
les rôles des hommes et des femmes dans
les sociétés qu'elle a traversée elle
ouvre une perspective assez tabou dans
la société américaine des années 30 qui
imaginent que les femmes et les hommes
ont des rôles dicté par la nature elle
affirme que la nature humaine est
presque entièrement malléable et que le
social prime sur le biologique
autrement dit le rôle assigné aux femmes
n'a rien de naturel
cette position ouvre dès lors la
possibilité pour les femmes de
revendiquer une meilleure place dans la
société
et même si à l'époque ces arguments sont
déjà avancés par les féministes margaret
midd a l'immense mérite de le prouver
par l'exemple son travail de terrain
démontrent que les relations entre
hommes et femmes ne sont pas partout
équivalente à une soumission totale de
ces dernières le modèle des arts à pêche
chez lesquels les hommes tout comme les
femmes ont un comportement doux et
aimable s'oppose au moun do more 200
kilomètres plus bas sur le fleuve qui
illustre le déchaînement de
l'agressivité masculine margaret mid
relie ces différences radical de
comportement à la manière dont les
enfants sont traités chez zara pêche
l'enfant fille ou garçon est soigné par
les deux parents toujours porté près du
corps les pleurs sont considérés d'après
elle avec beaucoup de sérieux et de
gravité et de manière générale une
attention constante est portée au
bien-être de l'enfant chez les moundou
goût mort en revanche les bébés sont
gardés dans des paniers assez grossier
loin de la chaleur corporelle des
parents l'allaitement est dit expédiées
et les enfants sont mis en compétition
dès le plus jeune âge hommes et femmes
se montrent alors agressif à l'âge
adulte
l'etg embolie la troisième société
qu'elle étudie lors de ce voyage
constitue dans ce modèle un type
intermédiaire les hommes ils sont rudes
et agressif mais les femmes
il montre beaucoup de calme et de
douceur c'est en fait un exemple parfait
de différenciation sexuelle l'éducation
différente des filles et des garçons
conduisant à ce contraste à l'âge adulte
pour margaret mid ce sont donc ces
expériences de la petite enfance
marquant profondément le caractère qui
donnerait à la société toute entière son
inclination pour la douceur ou la
violence en somme
dites moi comment vous traitez vos
enfants je vous dirais qu'il vous est il
faut avec la théorie est assez belle un
peu trop peut-être
mais je reviendrai tout à l'heure sur
les critiques qu'on peut lui faire en
1932 alors qu'elle est chez les deux
chambres ou lit avec son deuxième mari
réaux fortune margaret mid rencontre
gregory bateson un anthropologue anglais
ils passent tous les trois des centaines
d'heures à discuter sous la moustiquaire
de leur petite maison
margaret mille décrit ce moment comme
une apothéose intellectuelle betsson
apportant des éléments déterminants pour
ses propres recherches
mid par ailleurs déçu par l'attitude
froide et sévère de son mari sur le
terrain est touché par les petites
attentions de gregory bateson et ce qui
doit arriver arrive bien entendu mis des
personnes tombent amoureux et mythes se
sépare de réaux à son retour aux états
unis
avec gregory bateson son troisième et
dernier mary margaret mid entreprend de
compléter sa théorie est aussi sa vie
personnelle son troisième mariage
découle de son envie de devenir mère
coûte que coûte
l'attitude cruelle des moundou boomer à
l'égard de leur progéniture la décida
élevée elle même un enfant et benson
sera d'après elle un meilleur père que
ray aux fortunes malgré de nombreuses
fausses couches sont en vie reste
intacte à partir de 1936 le couple
réalise de nouveau terrain à ben ali
puis à nouveau au bord du sepik chez
layette moule le peuple qu'ils
étudiaient betsson avant de la
rencontrer
ensemble ils deviennent parmi les
premiers anthropologues a documenté
systématiquement leurs observations par
des photographies et des films
il ramène plus de 25 mille clichés et 70
kilomètres de pellicule de leur terrain
alors retour aux états unis mais il
parvient enfin à garder un enfant en
décembre 30,9
elle donne naissance à sa fille marie
catherine à partir de ce moment là même
si elle continue ses recherches
mais il ne peut plus absente et aussi
longtemps et son travail suscite moins
d'intérêt bête ça lui poursuit d'autres
objets d'étude et sans la passion
intellectuelle d'une recherche commune
sur le terrain le couple finit par se
séparer en 1950 les dernières décennies
de la vie de margaret midi sont
consacrés à des engagements plus
politique
elle lutte contre la faim dans le monde
ou contre le racisme réfléchit à la
condition humaine contemporaine
elle meurt à new york en 1978
après sa mort l'oeuvre de marguerite mid
continue de diviser
elle bénéficie d'une grande popularité
auprès du public alors que ses écrits
sont vivement critiquées par ses
collègues
plusieurs ouvrages ont même été publiée
pour tirer au clair les controverse à
son sujet en 1983 derek freeman critique
très fermement la vision des sannois par
margate mid
il revient notamment sur les conditions
de son enquête il rappelle que margaret
mid ne parlais pas la langue locale
qu'elle résidait à l'écart des
autochtones et qu'elle n'a basé son
étude que sur le témoignage d'une
vingtaine de jeunes filles il est sans
doute vrai que l'étude de maria ait hmid
aux samoa est un peu légère mais à y
regarder de plus près on se rend compte
que la démarche de freeman n'est pas non
plus exempte de tout reproche
il as a passé beaucoup plus de temps aux
samoa qu'humide mais c'est un formateur
ne sont pas forcément plus fiables là où
elle avait interrogé deux jeunes femmes
d'un milieu modeste lui privilégie le
discours des hommes plus âgés et
jouissant d'une position dominante dans
la société
de nombreux entrepôts log ont donc
accuser freeman de vouloir démolir
margaret mid à tout prix sans faire
preuve de nuance
d'autant qu'il s'agissait là du premier
terrain d'une femme de 24 ans dans les
années 20 et que les voyages suivants
ont fait la preuve de son sérieux entre
huit mois et 2 ans sur place
apprentissage méticuleux de la langue
locale documentation systématique et
méthodique bref difficile de la coincer
sur la rigueur méthodologique
s'il paraît excessif d'accuser margarit
mythe de malhonnêteté intellectuelle
il est vrai que ces approches souffrait
de plusieurs biais en cherchant à
expliquer la société américaine à
travers le miroir des sociétés
primitives mille d'efforts mais sans
doute sa vision des peuples qu'elle
étudiait représenter les haras pêche et
les moundou mort comme des archétypes de
tempérament doux ou agressif paraît
aussi très réducteur et d'ailleurs en
partie contestés par les observations de
son deuxième mari après la mort de mid
sa fille marie catherine benson a aussi
révélé au grand public ce que certains
savaient déjà de longue date
sa mère a longtemps entretenu une
relation amoureuse avec sa collègue et
ami mouss bénédicte malgré leurs quinze
ans d'écart
elle noue une relation très intense
elle relie tous leurs travaux respectifs
ce écrivent des poèmes de vienne à
nantes et vivent ensemble par
intermittence soucieuse de ne pas faire
scandale et de ne pas nuire à leur
carrière universitaire mais il n'a
jamais révélé cette relation qu'il a
pourtant beaucoup influencé d'après son
expérience personnelle midd a en effet
affirmé que tous les humains sont
bisexuels à l'origine et que leur
éducation les conduit à privilégier un
type de sexualité une généralisation qui
a elle aussi subi beaucoup de critiques
en réalité une grande partie des
reproches qu'on peut faire à
marguerittes mid sont une conséquence de
son envie d'être utile mid en fait
toujours eu à l'esprit que ces écrits
devait être utile au public que son
propos devaient pouvoir passer
clairement et quitte à choquer agir
concrètement dans la société
et le fait est qu'elle y est parvenu les
études sur le genre et identité sexuelle
se sont multipliés
cent ans plus tard sa vision des
rapports entre hommes et femmes reste
une inspiration pour différents
mouvements féministes ou lgbt
[Musique]
merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo pour
soutenir ce travail direction tipi
n'hésitez pas aussi à cliquer sur la
clochette pour être tenu au courant de
la reprise en septembre et d'ici là je
ne vous quitte pas tout à fait il y à un
standard passé sauvage sur instagram
alors là on a un programme digne du club
med rando roller jardinage poésie bref
n'hésitez pas à passer
je vous souhaite un très très bon et et
profitez-en et on se retrouve en
septembre salut
[Musique]